- Hi everyone, Sal Khan here.
Welcome to the Homeroom live stream.
We have a very exciting guest today.
We're gonna have John Dickerson,
who is, works for 60 Minutes, CBS
contributing analyst,
contributes to the Atlantic
and also has written, "The
Hardest Job In The World."
So a lot to talk about, especially
with the election coming up
and kind of our government
and the history of United States.
If you have any questions about that,
feel free to start putting
them in the message boards,
wherever you are watching this.
Then our team members
are going to surface it
to myself and John.
But before we jump into that
very exciting conversation,
I'll give my standard reminders.
First of all, reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization
and we can only do what we
do with philanthropic support
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to Khanacademy.org/donate
and making a donation.
Also want to give a special shout out
to several organizations that
have stepped up during COVID.
When they realized that
we were already running
a deficit before COVID
and that deficit only grew
as we had to have higher server costs
and accelerate a whole bunch of programs.
So special thanks to Bank Of America,
Google.org, AT&T, Fastly, Novartis
and the many, many other supporters
that have supported Khan
Academy through the years.
And especially all of
y'all who've continued
to support us through COVID.
It's the only way we can do what we do.
And the last announcement,
just reminding everyone
that you can get a version
of this live stream in podcast format
or wherever you get your podcasts,
Homeroom with Sal, the podcast.
So with that I'm excited to
introduce John Dickerson,
60 Minutes correspondent,
CBS contributing analysts.
You contribute to the Atlantic.
You do a lot of things.
I mean, any one of the things
I just mentioned would be
more than a full-time job,
but good to see you John.
- It's great to be with you again Sal.
- So maybe a good place to
start, I have a ton of questions,
but obviously we're days
away from an election.
You know every election I
think always feels special
and different, but this one feels
more different than normal.
Obviously it's happening in
very unusual circumstances.
How are you thinking about it?
- Well, I think you're right.
There's, so the most the basic
reason it feels different
is that we are holding
or trying to hold an election
in the time of a pandemic.
So that every vote tasked and counted
is under different scrutiny state.
Some States have had to create
entirely new ways of voting.
So that would be, just be
the basic big challenge
of the moment where in.
We are also in an highly
contentious moment
in which the president who
is usually the guardian
and steward of that system,
which is the bedrock
of the American system,
which is a form for voting that
allows the peaceful transfer
of power or the peaceful
maintenance of power.
It's basically the first block
in the building block
of American government.
The president has been
questioning, challenging,
poking, prodding at that basic brick
in the structure of America,
by questioning whether
the votes will be honest,
whether the vote counting
and the way it's being done
is somehow gonna throw
the result into question.
So you have the voting in a pandemic,
and then you have the, basically
the most popular well-known
figure in American politics
calling that into question.
So those are just two things.
And then of course you
have a series of issues
that are at the center of the election,
which are major and big
and need to be addressed.
Pandemic is one, the economic
situation in America is other,
is the other.
And then the ongoing
racial debate questions,
protests about equality in America
and whether that is broadly
shared or broadly available to,
and particularly to Black Americans.
- And how do you think,
I know predicting the future
is always a hard thing to do,
but let's try a little bit.
How do you think it's going to play out?
Given everything you just talked about,
on election day, this isn't
gonna be a typical election day,
whereby midnight or 1:00
AM people are gonna say,
"Oh it looks like, so-and-so
is the next president."
- Here's what I'm looking for in terms
of the way it plays out.
The one thing to watch is right now,
the early vote that's taking place
both in person and by mail.
There were some States
like Florida and Arizona
that start the counting early.
And those are States that we
should all kind of look to
on election night.
I become particularly
interested in Arizona.
They start counting two weeks before,
they've been voting early since 1996.
So they're pretty good at doing it.
About 90% of the vote will be counted
before election day in Arizona,
which means you're gonna have durable,
a durable counting process there.
And so we're gonna, so we
have the early vote going on,
then we look at the States
that are able to process those
votes so that we'll get an
answer on election night.
And then we've gotta look at the votes
that are being cast on election day.
And one of the splits
people should look for
is that a lot of Democrats
are voting early.
It's likely that the bulk
of the Republican vote
will be on election day.
So we should all be
prepared for some numbers
that come in that show,
perhaps Joe Biden winning
because of the early vote,
but then maybe change once some States
start to count their
in-person vote during the day.
And we should all be ready and prepared
if it's a close election,
for the election to be determined maybe
into the next day after election day,
or maybe even some days down beyond that.
On the other hand, early in the evening,
we'll get from some East
coast States, Florida,
North Carolina in particular,
Georgia that will tell us
something about the way
the night is trending.
And it could be, even
though everybody is prepared
for a long election week,
it could be that we get a
signal early in the night
from some of those States
that it's gonna go one way,
because the turnout is just,
being for one candidate or another,
and we could get an early result.
So everybody's preparing
for a long counting process,
but that doesn't mean that's
the only kind of answer
we might get once the votes
started being counted.
- And I just wanna make sure
I understand the logistics
or how the information gets out
as we approach election day.
So even in a place like Arizona,
where they start the
counting ahead of time,
do they release that
information as they have it?
Is that where we see like,
the precincts reporting and all that.
How does it get out there?
- This is my favorite fact
about Arizona at the moment,
the counting is going on and
it is in a computer somewhere.
The tabulation, so what they do is that
they open the ballot,
they check the information
on the ballot against the voter file.
They check the signatures,
they make sure it's
an actual valid ballot
and then they tabulate it.
Those tabulations are
sitting in a computer
and we'll sit in a computer
until election day.
It's not hooked up to the internet.
It is a number inside the
computer that nobody knows.
Then once the polls close
in Arizona on election day,
they will release that tabulation.
So that's the tabulation of the early mail
and in-person vote.
And so you'll get a big
kind of gurgle of results.
And then slowly over time,
they will add in the
votes on election day.
And so those votes by
machine on election day,
but then also some people will drop off
their ballots on election day,
which means that they've
gotten an early valid,
and then it will have to be assessed.
They'll compare the signatures,
they'll compare it to the voter roll.
And so that'll take a little bit of time,
Arizona even though
they have a time tested,
well stressed vote by mail process.
They've had some elections
recently where the result on
election night has been different
than the results several
days later because of
that counting process.
Now that's just in Arizona.
Every state has a different process.
It's why some of the States
people are most fascinated by
Pennsylvania, Michigan, and Wisconsin.
Those are three States that
Donald Trump won in 2016,
which was a part of his
surprise, upset victory.
Those are, I call them the headache States
because Pennsylvania doesn't
start processing ballots
until election day.
So their process is kind of slow
and it may mean that
we don't get a result.
If those States are close,
you may not get a result for a few days.
And there will be lots
of things to bicker over
in the way that they count their ballots.
So every state does it differently,
some better than others.
- And a lot of questions
are coming in related
to what you just talked about
from YouTube Mark R. Thompson says,
"why can't all States do
what Arizona is doing?"
- (laughs) Well we may that
they may all start to try
and do that.
The principle has been that local control,
in the United States where
this is best handled by people
closest to the ones
doing the actual voting.
And the upside also of it is
when we think about hacking and disruption
from foreign adversaries
or anybody who would try
to seize power in America
from a local perspective,
very hard to do when you have many,
many different kinds of voting systems.
And so in a way, the
inefficiency of having
so many different systems
has a slight benefit in that
it's harder to disrupt.
Because you'd have to learn how
to disrupt each little play,
each little County sometimes.
And in some States, the rules
are different by County.
So there's a way in which the inefficiency
actually protects us a little bit
but and I should just add,
we have tried as a country
to reform our voting process
during the Ford administration,
Carter administration,
Obama administration,
and they are big binders full of analysis
on how to make voting easier and better
and it never quite happens
for variety of reasons in part
because the federal government
can't tell the States
what to do.
But maybe after the embarrassing
delays and confusion here,
there might be, maybe
there'll be a new push
to improve things.
- I like that point.
That was the first time I
heard kind of our fragmentation
of our voting system as
a feature and not a bug.
But it doesn't make sense.
It does make it harder to
game because you have to
game it at at least at a state level,
probably at a local level.
And that goes into another question,
you alluded to the fact that
Donald Trump has said a few
times that he's skeptical
of some of the mail-in early
voting that may be the election
might be called into question
from YouTube, Mr. Spector's asking,
"will it be a fair election?
How will they make sure the votes are fair
and nothing is rigged?"
- Well each of the individual States
and the secretaries of
States in the States will,
has a process for doing that.
Part one thing people should
really keep in mind is that,
a lot of these States
and particularly ones
that have close elections,
have a time tested an honored
way of figuring out whether
there's any fraud.
The reason there is so little fraud
is it's really hard to do and
when they have found fraud
on election day or through
voting, it's been found out.
So it might take a little
while in some States
because they have a kind of
multi-level process to make sure
that the voting that's taking
place is honorable and true.
But the length of time
that it's taking means
that they are doing their work.
They are checking their,
they're doing their math again,
they're not rushing through the process.
And so delay and it might
be a little irritating
in this world where we
would all like everything
instantaneously, but it is
the sign of diligent work
going forward that is
actually gonna protect
the durability of the vote.
So what we can rely on is
the systems within the States
and the fact that everybody's
been worried about
what voting in a pandemic
is gonna be like.
And so there are a lot of
people who are watching
and while some States have
had rigorous debates over
the number of polling places
and the number of drop-offs
spots for early ballots,
there are a lot of
people paying attention.
And so it's a little bit
harder to do a slight of hand
or some kind of fraud
with so many eyes on what's taking place.
- And, one thing that you brought up
and that you talking about
that gives me confidence
in what is happening.
But even in your kind of,
it sounds like almost not worst case,
but not great scenarios.
You have it maybe a few
days past election day.
I was hearing these scenarios,
I haven't heard them as much
recently where people think
"it might take weeks
and it might be disputed
and it might go, depending
on how it's disputed,
if some States don't wanna say
that they've have a final tally,
that it could go to
the state legislatures.
I've been hearing all of
these other kinds of Byzantine
worst-case scenarios.
Do you think any of those are
happening or is that just kind
of scaremongering of like an
absolute disaster scenario?
- Well it's a good question.
I could cook up some
truly awful scenarios.
I mean basically the
closer it is, the more
Turkey it might get.
Because a, if it's closed, it means that
every tiny little vote
really could matter.
Remember what happened in 2000 in Florida,
you had a committee of
people obsessing about
the tiny pieces of paper that
hung from the punch ballots,
the chads as you'll remember.
Which really showed how you
can funnel the entire intensity
of the American political system
and the power that is
exchanged in elections
down to a tiny piece of paper that is
basically barely bigger
than the head of a pencil.
So it can get really weird, really fast,
and if it's not close however,
then there might be some sloppiness.
There always is in an election.
It's a massive undertaking.
We might have, you know, between 150,
160 million people in America.
It is not something that ever goes off
with a hundred percent purity
just because of human
activity at that scale
has bumps and messiness
and an occasional untucked shirt tail.
But if it's not close,
a little messiness can be
accommodated by the overwhelming
result for one of the two candidates.
And I think that it,
so basically I've tried not
to sketch the total disaster
scenarios because while
people are prepared for them
and everybody should be emotionally
prepared for complexity.
I also think if we get to up on tiptoe
and get to talk too much about
how awful it all could be,
it sets the stage for mischief makers
who some of whom are domestic,
some of whom are from our adversaries.
Who in a highly heightened and
atmosphere can throw in just
a little this information
and if everybody's already
so keyed up that little bit of information
will cause people to go
pinballing all over the place.
And so one of our jobs in the press
is to try to keep the eye on the ball,
what's the most important thing
and not go through a
kind of doom scrolling
of all the possible, awful
things that might happen.
And in fact, teach people
or remind people that,
this is going to be a developing
story on election night
and to ignore rumors and
to practice some restraint
in handling the incoming information.
Because it might take
a slightly winding path
and don't mistake the natural winding
for the electro counting process
for anything having gone wrong.
If they do that, there will
be less chaos on election day.
- You're touching on
actually the next question
that has come through on this notion
of foreign influence mischief maker,
polarization from Facebook.
John Lavelle asks,
"the foreign influence
that has taken place
in our country has fueled
the division that threatens
the union and has been very successful.
The two tribes are at each other's throat.
The question is who has
helped widen the gap?"
And I'll expand that a little bit.
I do sometimes wonder how successful have
the foreign influence actually been?
It seems like there's evidence
that it's been going on,
but how successful has it been?
Or has it been more of our
own making through
polarizations or social media,
or even the media itself
changing and kind of polarizing?
- Well the answer to that question is yes,
which is to say that certainly
we had foreign adversaries
who were trying through a
variety of different methods,
Facebook groups, phony ads,
attempts at voter suppression
to tinker with American politics.
But I think one of the
most potentially powerful
things they did was
in a nation where political
combat is so corrosive
among the highly online
and the highly engaged,
which is not the majority of our country
and it's not even the majority
of voters, but nevertheless
it does represent a lot
of people on social media
who can affect news
coverage, who can affect
the culture in which voting takes place.
That's where when you throw disinformation
into the middle of that kind of swarm,
where we're already
bickering and short-tempered
and questioning motives
in our political debate,
it has an explosive effect.
So it's not, in some cases
it's not even misinformation.
It's just the coarsest
possible information,
which then causes a reaction
and a counter reaction
from each side.
So the partisanship in America
among political obsessives
has gotten much, much worse,
both in the way they
think about the parties
and the way in which they think about
the opposite members of the party.
As you know about the
polling that long ago people
who were political
obsessives would be okay
with one of their
offspring marrying somebody
of the other party.
Now that number is down.
It might be in the teens
of political obsessives,
who would be all right with
one of their offspring,
marrying a member of the other party.
Those are the political obsessives.
There's also a lot of
work that's done on voters
that finds that basically
about 80% of the voters
are not obsessed and
thinking the absolute worst
of the other party.
Now they can get there pretty fast.
If you get into a conversation
with them and you misbehave
and you treat them as,
subhuman because of the
party they belong to.
But mostly the people
who spend a lot of time
on social media and the people who are,
who represent the worst
in our political dialogue
are actually a relatively small percentage
of the electorate, and an
even smaller percentage
of the American people.
- And, we this polarization,
where you think it's gonna lead to?
Do you think it depends on
the outcome of the election?
Do you think we have some just,
structural trends because of social media
and it's not like the
Russians and the Iranians
and the Chinese are gonna
disappear overnight?
I mean, is there some way
that we converge back to,
and is there any lessons from
history that tell us that
"okay we can clearly,
I mean obviously we've had a civil war,
so things have gotten bad in the past."
How do we heal?
What's it gonna look like in 20 years?
- Yeah well the civil war example
is the most dangerous one of course,
which is that we only heal
after we tear ourselves apart.
And so you'd hate to have
to see reform come out
of that kind of hot stove moment
because of the carnage that would be
required to create that
kind of wake up call
for the whole country.
There are, I mean I
think the best case for
getting out of our current fix
is probably a combination of two things.
One would be a considerable
political defeat
of one of the two parties,
which would change the
political incentives
for the individual members in the party
to not listen to the base of their party
but listen to the larger country.
The problem is and I'm
gonna be general here,
although, at the moment,
because Donald Trump is the president,
the power he holds over Republicans
in his party is tremendous.
And you know as Jared Kushner says,
"this is Donald Trump's Republican party."
And so if you're a Republican
member of the House or Senate,
you are judged by your
president and also the partisans
in your party by whether or
not you support Donald Trump.
Well, that's not really the way(laughs)
the founders intended to operate.
They wanted a system in which
lawmakers use their reason
to evaluate the questions of the day
and political affiliation
and maintaining political
power was what they feared.
But the system is where it is.
So what you need is something
to happen that breaks the link
between individual members of a party
and the group interest of that party.
That basically says to people,
"geez just supporting my team
has caused this enormous electoral loss.
I should probably go back to what
the people want me to care about,"
which is whatever it happens to be.
And so you sever the extreme adhesion
between individual
candidates and their parties.
One of the ways you do that is,
and that has to probably
happen through an event.
In other words a massive electoral loss.
It would then potentially
open the door to some reforms.
And what the reforms would
do is they would break down
the structural impediments
to bipartisanship,
which I won't go into,
but which I go to into in
some length in my book.
But which the death of
split ticket voting,
the fact that we all live near each other
and therefore, if you're a Republican,
you tend to live on a block
full of Republicans now
in a way that you didn't in the seventies.
Gerrymandering all kinds
of other structural parts
of the system that
accentuate partisanship,
you would need something to
basically have some reforms
that would break apart those
structural sorting techniques
that have created, or I
shouldn't say they've,
they both created and
locked in the partisanship
we have now.
- Yeah, no I mean, it's
a fascinating thing
of how it could evolve,
but that makes a ton of sense.
Going to your book, "The
Hardest Job In The World"
were you're referring to the presidency,
I can think of other hard jobs too,
but that one does seem hard.
From YouTube niche786 says,
"you make the case in "The
Hardest Job In The World"
that the demands of the
American presidency have grown
impossible for any one person to fulfill.
What problems does that pose?"
And I'll add to niches's question,
how do you fix that?
I mean, it sounds like a
pretty hard thing to fix.
- Well thank you for the question
and thanks for reading the book.
So we were talking about
just some of the problems
with the modern presidency,
which is partisanship,
which has locked up Congress,
which means that the president no longer
has a willing partner
or no longer has the
willing partner of the kind
that the founders wanted in Congress.
Something that operates
independently to address
the big challenges of the day
in a way that accommodates
the diversity of the country.
What we have now is as Congress
is less able to do its job effectively,
a lot of the decision-making
gets thrown over
onto the president's plate.
And then the president has to use
the weak tools of the office,
which are not universally
applicable to all the problems of
the day to through executive
orders and other ways to try
to address some of the issues
that Americans care about.
Well, executive orders
and executive action
and work through the
administrative agencies
is a weak way to do it,
basically it doesn't get the job done.
And when presidents act in ways
that are seen as unilateral
by the opposite political party,
it encourages the opposite
political party to be very angry.
If you can work things through Congress,
the opposite political
party at least has a voice
and a structure.
Now some people would argue
about that with respect
to the recent Supreme court
fights that have gone on.
But nevertheless, when Congress
is working as it's intended,
it's basically a structure
for having arguments
and for seeing who wins that argument,
and then at least making
the losers feel like
the system was fair
enough so that they'll,
they can live to fight another day.
What you don't want in any
system is where people feel like
they were basically
maneuvered by the structure
of the system to a bad result,
and they really couldn't change anything.
So some of the structural
changes in Congress
we've been talking
about, we need to change.
The president, has accumulated
power ever since basically
you can put finger down
anywhere in the timeline,
but let's say basically the new deal
and the second world war.
So that's hard power to give back
and they don't want to do that.
But as Americans, we can
stop looking to the president
every time we want a political solution.
And we can stop rewarding
presidents who promised
that they alone can do it
as Donald Trump promised.
You need to elevate presidents who operate
in the American system as it should work,
not as an American system
in which they are the
lone superpower, sorry,
the lone superhero who can
through force of their will
and skill solve all of America's problems.
It's not the way the
government is supposed to work
and we should stop thinking
that's the way it's supposed to work,
'cause it just leads to frustration.
- Yeah although I wonder about that.
I mean, even in corporate
America we tend to have,
you know the CEO, we,
Elon Musk is sending rockets to space.
Well no it's Elon Musk
plus a lot of other people
are doing it.(laughs)
Steve jobs, and a lot of other people.
- Well but in the corporate
world at least that's,
there's the chance that
that's more likely to happen
because the CEO can have absolute power
if they've designed the
organization that way.
Even if a president wanted absolute power,
they don't have it.
And they, it's sort of
the worst of both worlds,
because if we think of them
as an all-powerful CEO,
but then don't give them
the tools to do the job,
then they both make claims
like they're gonna be the
Elon Musk of the government,
but then don't have the ability to do it.
And, there's not really
a feedback mechanism
that there is in the corporate world,
basically with the presidency,
there's one feedback
mechanism, reelection.
And most of them take
intermediate feedback mechanisms
if they lose a midterm or
if their polls go down.
But if a president has a
strong enough pain threshold
or a high enough pain
threshold, I should say,
they can power through
and face no real feedback
other than other than the
election after four years,
because Congress is no
longer a feedback mechanism.
Because everything is so connected now,
if you are a Senator, basically
as a Republican Senator,
if you're running your voters wanna know
are you for the president or against him.
The rest is secondary.
And that's I say that
for having interviewed
a lot of Republican senators running.
- I could talk to you for hours,
especially given the world
that we're in right now,
but just in the last question,
as a member of the media
and the type of journalism
I've followed you many years,
even before we first met.
And we've had many
conversations like this,
even when we were non
cameras, I have deep respect.
You know you're kind
of like the journalist
that I always imagined, like the people
there trying to be the truth
seekers and they're reading
the history books and they're
writing the history books.
What do you, what advice would
you have for kids out there
who might be watching or
people of any age whose like
"well, you know we're not,
we're past Walter Cronkite somehow
and the fourth estate of the
journalism and social media
has somehow ruined everything.
And, there isn't, there's
everyone's version
of the truth now."
So what advice would you have to someone
who wants to become a journalist
and why should they be excited about that?
- Well, I think that my advice would be,
and it goes back to Khan Academy.
What is one of the great things
about what you've created?
It is to allow people
who are curious to learn
and to follow that curiosity.
And in the process of
following that curiosity,
develop the school, the skills
for understanding their world.
So critical thinking,
and curiosity and critical
thinking are necessary
to live a meaningful life, I think.
It turns out also
that they are what should
fuel you as a journalist.
And so one of the things I think,
whether you're interested
in journalism or not,
seeking out your own answers,
following your own curiosity,
not just what happened, but
why it happened for yourself,
not because you're skeptical
and you think everybody's
trying to lie to you,
but because you know
that when you investigate
the why of things, when you
go look it up on your own,
when you follow your own
path of your curiosity,
it's rewarding.
And you gain, in a democratic system,
you gain control over
the world around you,
by understanding what's happening.
Events don't come plopping on you,
you understand what's happening
and so you feel some
control in a frantic world
where things can seem out of control.
And so what I would say
is anybody who is curious
and a critical thinker
can then go get a job
where you have a license to be curious,
and hopefully use those
critical thinking skills
to follow your curiosity.
The final thing I would say is for anybody
who wants to become a journalist
or anyone who wants to
engage in journalism,
just like if they're
learning through Khan Academy
or any other learning process,
experimentation and understanding
is not a straight line.
There are things that we once
believed about the movement of
the planets and the heavens
that we've now changed our thinking about.
Einstein was a genius who saw ahead of
entire generations of thinkers,
but he also got a lot wrong.
And he, when he found out he
had gotten something wrong,
he didn't feel glum about it,
he was delighted because it meant
that he now knew the right answer.
He now could pursue a whole
new set of curiosities.
And I think as consumers of journalism
and of any information is to
understand that being wrong
is not always the product of
somebody who has ill intent
or somebody who is acting in bad faith.
There are plenty of
those people to be sure,
but if we understand that
the pursuit of knowledge
is sometimes a crooked path,
then we won't get all undone
every time we learn something
that we thought might not
be true the day before.
When we, accumulation of knowledge
is a kind of crooked path.
And we need to know that,
and we need to know that
about our journalism.
In its best form it's self-correcting,
the more you learn, the more you learn
and the better informed you are.
But we should make sure
we think of it in that way
and don't always think,
"Oh well, they said it
was gonna be this way
and it turned out to be that way.
And therefore, everything they
always say is without merit."
That's not true in life and
we shouldn't think about it
when it's not true in the way
we receive our information.
A little more understanding
of the way we receive our
information will help us
to be better informed.
- No, I love that.
And that seems applicable to
journalism, the media and life.
To just be constantly truth seeking
and not tying your identity, your ego
to a certain set current fact base,
and always be open to new ideas.
John thank you so much,
this was a real treat
especially given the timing.
Hopefully we can debrief
and see how correct your prognostications
were in a couple weeks or
months.(Sal laughs)(John laughs)
- Well, I would love to do it,
and it's always a pleasure to be with you.
So thanks for giving me the opportunity.
- Thank you John.
- See you Sal.
- So thanks everyone for joining,
always a fun conversation.
You know John really is
one of those journalists,
I've had the pleasure of getting
to have kind of just random
conversations with them
that go a lot like the
conversation we just had,
but he definitely gives you
a spark of curiosity around,
the messiness but also the beauty
of what makes a society a society,
what makes a government a government.
And I really do think he's,
that form of journalism
that we need a lot more of,
more than ever.
But just as a reminder for tomorrow,
another really great guest,
we're gonna have the Vivek
Murthy, former surgeon general
and kind of talk about, as you imagine
a lot of things healthcare,
what's going on with COVID
and probably a little bit of,
what the surgeon general does
in the role of government
and all of this as well.
So I'll look forward to
having that conversation.
So please join us tomorrow
with, on the Homeroom same time.
Talk to you all later.